with paragraph 166 we are now beginning
an entirely new section that of self
consciousness which many people identify
with one of the most famous passages in
Hegel's phenomenology the master-slave
dialectic but which as you'll see as we
go through this entire section has a lot
more going on than just that particular
dialectic I thought it would be
worthwhile to pause for a moment as I
did in the very first video talking
about the project in general to recap a
little bit of what we've gotten done and
talk about where we're going from this
point on so we've we've gone through
five major portions of this work and you
know if you look at it just in terms of
page lengths you see we've got through
about uh maybe a fifth of it we've
gotten through the preface which is
quite long we've gotten through the
shorter introduction and now we've gone
through the three main sections of
consciousness sense certainty perception
and force and the understanding we're
going to see this this first couple
paragraphs take up the themes from those
those previous sections and bring them
together and then we're going to move
into totally different material but
using some of the same dialectical tools
that we've now developed some of the
same movements are going to take place
but with different content very
different content something that's
important to keep in mind is as we're
proceeding further and further and
further into this work we're going away
from what originally presents itself as
being concrete but turns out to be most
abstract towards what will in fact turn
out to be more and more concrete more
and more identifiable with the
experience that we ourselves have as
consciousness so as we move now
to this new session of
self-consciousness we want to be
attentive to the changes that are taking
place and we also want to be mindful of
the sublation or ofhaving that is that
has occurred and bring along with us
everything that we've done so far
in the previous modes of certainty what
was true for consciousness is something
other than itself but the notion of this
truth vanishes in the experience of it
what the object immediately was in
itself mere being in sense certainty the
concrete thing of perception and for the
understanding of force proves to be in
truth not this at all
instead this in itself turns out to be a
mode in which the object is only for
another the notion of the object is
superseded in the actual object or the
first immediate presentation of the
object is superseded in experience
certainty gives place to truth but now
there has arisen what did not emerge in
these previous relationships that is a
certainty which is identical with its
truth for the certainty is to itself its
own object and consciousness is to
itself the truth in this there is indeed
an other 'no status to say a
consciousness makes a distinction but
one which at the same time is for
consciousness not a distinction if we
give the name of notion to the movement
of knowing and the name of object and
knowing as a pass of unity or as the I
then we see that not only for us but for
knowing itself the object corresponds to
the notion or alternatively if we call
notion what the object is in itself but
call the object what it is wha object or
for another then it is clear that being
in itself and being for another are one
and the same for the in itself is
consciousness but equally it is that for
which an other the in itself is and it
is for consciousness that the in itself
of the object and the being of the
object for another are one and the same
the eye is the content of the connection
and the connecting itself opposed to an
other the eyes its own self and at the
same time it over arches this other
which for the eye is equally only the
eye itself
as we begin section 166 and indeed begin
this entire movement of self
consciousness Hegel is going to
introduce two other terms that have been
used already but he's going to play them
off against each other in a way that
will run throughout much of the rest of
the phenomenology he's going to talk
about certainty or give insight the
state of being certain of something and
generally this is a kind of immediacy
and then truth VAR height truth is
generally going to be something that is
attained in the process something that
is is systemic something that is itself
mediated and we're going to see this
this constant process of going back and
forth between certainty and truth often
getting one of them and then realizing
that we've lost the other in the process
and now we need to work to get that back
or trying to bring the two of them
together into some sort of cohesive
whole will any of them spin off from
each other this is the way the
dialectical process is going to work now
Hegel in this paragraph and particularly
in the next paragraphs as well is going
to be thinking in terms of where we've
come we have consciousness and we're
trying to move towards
self-consciousness how are we going to
get to self-consciousness it's going to
be by relationship of consciousness with
its other and in this paragraph and for
the next few paragraphs following it's
not the other of consciousness as an
other consciousness that's going to be
very important in this section but
that's not quite where we are right now
it's rather consciousness and it's
awareness of its relationship with its
others so he's going to do kind of a
recap of what that is what that is
looked like in the last few sections so
he's going to say that consciousness
right he says in the previous modes of
certainty what is true
for consciousness is something other
than itself so we start with these three
different modes that we added three
different sections right sense certainty
perception understanding and force in
the understanding what consciousness has
been observing what consciousness has
been engaging with what consciousness
has seen dialectically develop and
unfold and unpack as we you know went
through these sections in something that
is different than itself now the
immediate certainty that we begin with
here he says in the case of sense
certainty is a mere being right you know
I see we've been through this already I
see the truck the truck confronts me as
an immediacy and then of course it
doesn't just stay like that it turns out
to be an object that is in space and
time it can be correlated to other
objects like itself there's a now
there's a here you know we've gone
through this whole dialectic right and
what that means is we move away from the
mere being that were certain of the
notion of the object that we have in
that case towards something else
likewise with perception we begin with
the concrete thing which then of course
your memory has qualities and we try to
figure out what does it mean for a thing
to have qualities and we go back and
forth quite a bit about that I don't
need to rehash that entire section
because you know you can go back to
those videos or at least go back to that
portion of the text and you remember
what took place there with the mirror
being of this week we got the universal
then we played out the universal some
more with a concrete thing and we're
gonna get something else going on over
here and then finally in the last
section we have force and the
understanding and we begin with sort of
the failure of these two to provide us
what we thought was going to be there
the understanding grasps things in terms
of force now we have something that's
not purely sensible or purely perceptual
something that is is you might say
cognized right cognized in the sense
that that's a distinctively human way
doing although these are distinctively
human as well and we grasp the object as
he says in itself as a force but it's
not going to remain just a force and we
just went through that whole section if
it didn't just remain a force that would
have been one paragraph long object as a
force we're done but instead it turns
out to imply a counter force and
reciprocity and laws and you know a
world and an inverted world in another
world and all these things wrapped up
together right you remember that entire
development so he says what the object
immediately was in itself we just talked
about that it turns out in in truth not
this at all instead the in itself turns
out to be a mode in which the object is
only for an other all right so this is
the truth like what certainty here is
where we start with when the truth is a
sort of a progress that we make into
grasping what the object is and the
object is really for another what's the
other in this case consciousness right
so the object is what it is not for some
other object but for the thing or the
being that is actually conscious of it
there is no in itself that's purely out
there totally detached from how the
object is for consciousness and notice
what Hegel is going to say here that's
really quite mind-blowing
he says that we're going from the notion
of the object the Griffith right the
notion not in the sense of the fully
developed you know because if the fully
developed concept that we were used to
talking about is the end product of all
this development but rather the object
as it is originally conceived by by
consciousness or at the mere notion of
it we might say the mere figment the
mere idea of it and we're proceeding to
grasp the actual object the actual
object of what of experience of their
farm
of what
not just experience in the sense of
perceptual experience but experience in
the sense of watching the dialectical
progression and seeing what's really
there so he says it turns out to be a
mode in which the object is only for and
other the notion of the object is
superseded in the actual object
superseded meaning taken to a more
concrete more developed more dialectical
stage of its you know presents to us I
wanted to say existence when all this is
existing its presents to us as
consciousness so he says what does this
mean certainty is giving way to truth
what we began with is not remaining what
it is when we begin with it because what
we have in that case is abstract the way
it really is for us when we examine our
experience turns out to be its truth
this is a bit of a different use of the
term truth then we get if we're relying
on something like a correspondence
theory of truth and this is something I
probably should say a little bit about
at this point correspondence theory of
truth says that things are actually not
things but a statement or a a thought is
true if and only if it expresses the way
things actually are and it's false if it
says something other than that right so
correspondence ie between language and
reality or thought in reality now that
gets a little bit tricky when the
reality is including or encompassing or
unfolding the very thought or language
and the agent of it within it you don't
have a vantage point from which you can
serve like map to on to each other that
very mapping ability is something that
consciousness itself is taking
roll it so you could say well you've got
reality as the ultimate ground or you
can say you have consciousness as the
ultimate ground that's idealism
that's what Hegel is working with here
oftentimes people want to contrast a
coherence theory of truth against a
correspondence theory of truth a
coherence theory of truth says that
truth lies in the coherence or the non
contradiction of a whole bunch of things
all lined up with each other still
conceived in in essentially
propositional terms that's not quite
what Hegel is doing here either he's
using truth in a way that refers to our
grasping what is really going on with
the object and all of its relations it
can be represented in language the very
fact of thinking it or representing it
is part of the process of its reality so
he goes on any sense certainty gives way
it gives place to truth but now there
has arisen what did not emerge in these
previous relationships we've gone
through these sections some very
important progress has taken place by
going through them but one of the things
that we don't have depicted here on the
board is the fact that consciousness now
through this has a relationship to
itself by grasping that the truth of
what is its other what is present to it
as an object turns out to be what it is
for an auditor and that that other is
indeed
consciousness consciousness has made a
vital advance so it becomes no longer
consciousness but self-consciousness so
what we get here he says a certainty
which is identical to its truth a
starting point which is identical to the
fully developed
on what that starting point included
that's what self-consciousness is able
to bring it as something new on the
scene all of this other stuff can't do
that there's like a disjunction between
the perception and what is being
perceived and even the truth of what is
being perceived right there's a
separation that's taking place that
doesn't have to be there or it doesn't
have to remain there in
self-consciousness that is why there's
an advanced being made so he goes on and
he says we now have a certainty which is
identical with its truth for the
certainty is to itself its own object
and consciousness is to itself the truth
so consciousness grasps its own
processes and what it's doing as being
involved in what we might call with
tongue and cheek this truth making
process or progress away from what is
immediate it is both what is immediate
and what the immediate is transformed
into now we need to do a little bit of a
ratio to go through the rest of this
section so you'll notice that I have
some new schemas written here on the
board and these are useful for
understanding what's going on in the
rest of section 166 which says some
rather at least on the surface
paradoxical things we can't totally
represent them graphically on a
two-dimensional space but this is about
as good as it's going to get unless we
do some transformative motion things
which we can't do it was so easily
withdrawn so he says that
self-consciousness makes a distinction
which is at the same time not a
distinction again this is something
we've seen Hegel saying this distinction
that's not a distinction we want to
remind ourselves what that means is that
there is indeed the possibility of
distinguishing but it turns out that
there isn't some sort of substantial
ground in which these things are
distinguished where they're totally
separate things so to actually take up
an old adage from Scholastic theology
and philosophy you can say that that
distinction is not the same thing as
separation I use separation into two
independently existing things so he says
if there is indeed an other Ness that is
to say consciousness makes a distinction
in this if there's other Ness but one
which is at the same time for
consciousness not a distinction now why
not a distinction because really all
these things are connected with each
other in self-consciousness that's part
of what it means for consciousness to be
self-consciousness he talks about two
different complimentary ways of looking
at the relationship between the notion
and the object didn't remember what we
just talked about before was we were
going from the notion that with
certainty to the truth which was the
object but then we realized that this is
all within consciousness and now we're
talking about a certainty that is its
own truth or a truth which is is
beginning from that that certainty and
encompassing it so he talks first about
if we call the notion the movement of
knowing and then the object the passive
unity or the I the the being that is
doing the knowing where is where is the
relationship going here the paths of
unity is also at the same time active
because it's involved in the knowing but
there's a transformation that's taking
place as well so he says we see that not
only for us but for knowing itself the
object corresponds to the notion so
there's a corresponding on the part of
the passive unity or the I the one who
is perceiving with the move
knowing which means that this passivity
isn't really so passive and this pure
movement isn't just pure movement it's
being supported by the I on the other
hand II says if we want to call notion
what the object is in itself that the
beginning point right that we just
talked about and then we want to call
the object what it is Quan object-- or
what you know to be an object means to
be an object for and other that's that's
implied in the very notion of object
object isn't an object without a subject
so if we do that then we move in a
different direction or we realize that
these are actually identical that the
object in itself the object as it is
supposedly separate from any sort of
subjectivity and then the object as it
is for another that is for a
subjectivity are indeed the same thing
that's not actually going to hold by the
way for all of the objects like for
example piece of truck
it is however going to hold for one
important kind of object that is self
consciousness that's what we're talking
about here right so he says for the in
itself it is consciousness but equally
it is that for which and other the in
itself is and it is for consciousness
that the in itself of the object of the
being of the object for another are one
in the same that's what I'm trying to
represent down here right we have a
consciousness which is the in itself a
conscious thing it is indeed a thing
right it is an entity it does have
existence I as consciousness exists in a
determinant way as dr. Gregory Sadler or
as the guy wearing this particular
jacket and tie at this point in time
whereas those bits of data you know
somewhere in the ether that are there
encompassed by this video so there is it
in itself right and that is
consciousness at the same time
consciousness extends outside of just
that in itself and every object that is
in itself like we see here by being an
object it is for another this is
something by the way that we saw in
perception already and in Senate
certainty right now that other is also
consciousness and these are not
different consciousnesses it's not like
consciousness is split asunder into all
sorts of worrying or jarring or a
competing consciousness it's the same
thing right the other that it is for is
indeed consciousness when we make
ourselves objects for ourselves we're
occupying two roles we are both the the
object that's being you know looked at
by another and we are also the the
subject that's doing the looking but
we're also this is very important doing
the looking at that object as that
object is a subject that's a little
complex and we're gonna see that get
parsed out even more as time goes on you
notice that I've got drawing down here
this arcs between the two and the eye
the the ego the Hegel is going to say
the in itself is consciousness equally
it is that for which another is and it
is for consciousness that the in itself
of the object and the being of the
object for another our one on the same
the eye is the content of the connection
right what is the content of the
connection all that's going on here what
it is that the self consciousness is
grasping about itself as consciousness
that is the content of the connection in
the eye is also the very connection
itself now that's an interesting thing
to say an angle is just going to sort of
leave that hanging there and not follow
up on that but I think it's worth saying
a few more words about it let's see what
else he says that he says opposed to an
other the eye is its own self and at the
same time it over arches this other
what's the other its own self right
which for the eye is equally only the
eye itself so in the very act of being
able to think I or take a stance or even
more importantly say I we're already
involved in this entire dynamic where we
are taking a position upon ourselves
that's something that we do without even
really thinking about it most of the
time that's because it is part of our
very nature as self-consciousness
so notice to go back to this we're
making a distinction within something in
which there is strictly speaking no
separation into it you know a
distinction in two separate things but
it is still distinguishable and we do
that every time that we use this eye to
make sense of ourselves and what we're
positioned in relation to so our
self-consciousness isn't just a sort of
you know primal navel-gazing it's
already quite complex
it's differentiated right there's no
there's a distinction or a difference
there but it's one that is held together
in a synthetic unity
you